so I've been running my vlog project for
five weeks now and I've had a whole heap
of questions which I hope in order to
address in the comment section just
because of academic life and whatnot so
I thought I'd collect all the answers
together in one video and hopefully this
will be useful to people in the future
so I need to get to all of these in like
ten minutes so let's go it's easy to say
slice outside of college to what extent
are you bound to your courage in terms
of events slash social activities um I
think it depends on what you make of it
like I tend to socialize I'd say with
ninety percent of people I socialize
with are members of my college purely
because I don't do any activities on a
university-wide scale which really
encourage socializing like if I was to
do sport on any level obviously I
socialize with other members of my team
or crew or whatever but I just go to the
gym and that's obviously a solitary
activity I play in a band but we're not
the kind of man that goes to the
periphery afterwards so I'd also the
fact that I do physics and we're not
known as being a researcher subject
although that's said I get along really
well with a bunch of visit system of the
colleges and in particular personally me
and the other girl from some pieces get
on really well with us in hilda's
physicists just because that series has
started sitting next to and lectures in
first year so um you know there are
people other colleges I personally
socialize with but I do most of my
socializing and going out with people in
water
from sand Peters there are people who do
much more university-wide scale and
those are the people that tend to do
those things like sport and a union by
basis or do like language courses or the
kind of things that mean you interact
with people from other colleges but
certainly no stigma attached with doing
that it's just it's kind of convenient
to stick with some Vitas but were the
best college so why would you want to go
anywhere else how stressful did I find
adapting to Oxford life in a word very
I'll stick with very basically I
mentioned in a previous video that my
first term in Oxford was some of the
worst weeks of my life and there was a
whole raft of reasons as to why that was
I think it was a mix of the whole being
a big fish in a small pond going into a
tiny minnow in an ocean mixed with
being in a long-term relationship that
sooner became a long-distance long-term
relationship and not even see my
girlfriend all the time was difficult
plus the sheer workload in particular in
first year the workload was just
cataclysmic me there's a cataclysmic an
increase on what I was doing in a level
especially after such a long summer
break you know you get a really long
celebrate to the end of your 13 and the
south your first year uni so it was a
lot of factors at once that really
always cracked me and I know that a lot
of people have a very similar experience
in their first term of struggling to
adapt but you do adapt and some people
do take it like a duck to water and it's
not something that should put you off
flying but yes it is extremely stressful
being here but ultimately you need at
some point to make that jump between six
for more school and university and life
more broadly because life isn't like
school life is more hectic busier and
you need to adapt to that and in a way
you come into Oxford or going to any of
these prestigious universities that
cause you to work all the time getting a
job after that it's actually going to be
a bit easy by comparison it's gonna feel
easy our society student-run if so where
they get such professional lecturers yes
well the physics society which presume
you're talking about is gene run we have
a committee from all across the
university so our president Emily is
from Queens College our secretary is
from some pieces as I am the head of
publicity our social secretary is from
Mansfield where a bunch of visitors from
all across the years that were elected
by our peers to you to run the society
and in terms of getting the lecturers
really we just ask I mean we've had
people like Roger Penrose in the past
Jocelyn Bell Burnell we had Steven Blum
though several times including this week
these are just people that you email and
hope and if they say yes then you'll fit
them into the schedule and if there's a
lot of them say no then you just move on
so you know we will send emails to these
people to people like Daria Breen and
Jim Parsons and you know people like
that that are so out of our leaves but
if you don't ask you don't get basically
what does a common problem
you look like there's no really there's
no such thing as a common problem sheet
hang on so this one is a secondary
electromagnetism problem it's give you a
rough idea this is the second problems
that of new material of the term you've
got questions 15 questions though from
memory I think we split this into two
different weeks worth of work so we did
like eight question or makin seven
questions the next week so the first
part you've got like four questions of
revision two questions online it it
dipoles for questions or magnetizable
material there five questions of
magnetizable materials and then a couple
of questions at the end on lecture
dynamics and you know they vary
sometimes you'll get a long question
it's got lots of lots and lots of parts
like an example and this one would be
you've got uniformly charged sphere
what's the magnitude dipole on the
moment the sphere approximate vector
potential at the point a particular
point outside point inside and then
checking the boundary conditions between
the two so that's an example of a longer
problem but then at the same time on
this question ten is just estimate the
magnetic field needed to levitate a frog
it's because orders a paramagnetic
material frogs are mostly water as are
we I can't remember actually what was
the answer off the top of my toe quite
large about sixteen Tesla but like I say
there's no such thing as a as a standard
problem sheet they can vary from like
seven to eight questions to thirty
questions and you might not be asked to
do all living in particular go how hard
was it meeting new people and making
friends when you first started at uni
now I was extremely lucky with this I
think a lot of people go into their
freshers week for this mentality of I
must socialize or I will never have
friends ever for the next three years
and it's like I socialize with I kind of
attitude but when I came to Oxford and
came to some Peters I instantly felt so
at home you know I brought so much of
home with me like my parents that came
up with me in the car and we will round
to the rafters with stuff that you never
actually ended up using during the term
and yet I was left
topped off by my parent and I felt
instantly at home in some pieces I was
greeted by people in high years that's
how they are peers and made to feel at
home
learning people's names helped other
people move into their rooms met people
in the bar during the freshers week
events and it felt kind of effortless
really I never felt like I consciously
had to all gone I need to make friends
with this person or I'm never gonna have
friends it just kind of happens I I
really didn't have any significant
difficulties at all coming here in terms
of making friends I don't know if that's
just some Peters thing we are renowned
for being the friendly College in the
university but I really didn't have any
trouble I was I'm very lucky to go say
that I like more hard-working to move
her to the average Oxford student I
think quite possibly I work more hours
than the average Oxford student and by
average I mean that's across all
sciences or humanities all years or
because I definitely work less than a
lot of people who are doing science
subjects particularly like a PhD level I
work more now than I did in say my
second or third year that lessened in my
first year because in first I worked too
hard no burned out but to be honest I
think I work if I'm gonna say that I
work more hours in the average student
that's just because I need to because I
don't perceive myself as being as
intelligent as the average physicist on
the oxford course I feel like I need to
put more work in in order to get the
right answers out and that's what I'm
here to do so that's something I do do
how do you not fall asleep while
meditating seriously bill it first thing
in the morning after you've woken up and
taken a shower because that's the most
away you're ever gonna be but I'd still
fall asleep oh my god this is a long
comment right question one
discrimination against poor people not
from the University or tutors in any way
I've never heard of anybody be
discriminated against by their tutors or
any authority position the only time
I've ever that happen is by frankly
wankers who are rich and assumable
people who like them but they're so few
and far between like instant pizzas I've
never had any trouble I just hear story
the occasional story of that happening
to people it's definitely not some of
this as widespread as people assume it's
thanks to the stereotype question - is a
theology department overrun with Bible
bashes with an atheist door right well
of the theologians at some Peters we've
had a mix of really hard
poor atheist and really bells and smells
Christine I think it would be fair to
say that the department is not overrun
by religious types there are obviously
gonna be a lot of religious people who
would do the course but an atheist would
Finn
absolutely fine and there are plenty of
people that I know personally who have
done absolutely fine on the course being
either atheist or agnostic open days are
they any good I don't actually remember
going to an open day for Oxford though I
did go to open days for other you knees
and they found them very useful because
it's like collecting all the information
that you could possibly want at once
with Oxford I think it's more important
to get on specific colleges open days
and it's because you're gonna know the
course you want to apply to and all that
kind of thing but it's the big College
opening day which you would want to go
to because that's what's gonna decide to
your experience in Oxford and by that I
mean you should come to this and Peter's
College open days all extras like your
gown expensive um oh really
in terms of stuff like sofas if I
mentioned in previous video you need to
have a dark suit and to be honest by the
stage in life you'll need one when you
go to uni you know or just in life
generally like for weddings funerals
whatever it's that's I'm not gonna count
as an extra cost you did need to buy
your gown cap and white bow tie I think
rightly the like the tailored people did
a deal that was like 35 quid for all of
that in one and beyond that I think
that's all the extra stuff he needs to
get actually it's really not that
expensive green flashes how do they work
I don't really have the time to answer
that in this video
good question is intelligence enough to
get in no I know plenty of intelligent
people who would have gone into Oxford
didn't because they didn't put work in
because ultimately it's all one good
waltzing on to interview and being
incredibly intelligent and they're gonna
be impressed by that but unless you have
the hard currency of you're a lower
grades of you know GCSE words to back it
up it's kind of like taking you on trust
really you need intelligence but you
also need the gumption to work you need
an attitude which lends itself to hard
academic work because that's what you
need in order to survive here
so intelligence on his own is a
prerequisite that's necessary but not
sufficient condition is life after uni
Surry would you like to
forever yes please well actually I want
to become an academic I want to my dream
job is to become a lecture and in order
to do that I need to do a PhD which
necessitates sustain for a couple more
years hopefully here and then after that
attach myself to different units the
concepts of leaving Oxford is something
that I've obviously thought about a lot
because I'm a final year student but
it's something that I know is good to
come at some point I have to leave
Oxford whether I graduate or die and
it's something which doesn't necessarily
scare me that much I really love the
place I really do but I not the person
that wants to spend the rest of my life
in one place yeah I want to see the
world I want to experience living in
other countries and that kind of thing
so the ideal in Oxford isn't scary but
obviously it's a little bit sad because
whenever you leave anything you love
it's always gonna be sad bream tour I
know I'm a bad person I'm sorry I said
I'd do a room tour right okay I said
this week that on the internet that I
would do a in the life and I did so my
challenge next week is to do a room tour
I promise I will tidy my room beforehand
because at the moment you would not want
to apply here based on my room seriously
so everything I hope forever